each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a pleasure to introduce close to
beznosov was going to talk to us today
about user ma mental models of security
controls costa's um an associate
professor at University of British
Columbia in that just up the road in
Vancouver he's been visiting me here for
the last three weeks or so and we're
trying to get some stuff done together
and he's been you know very heavily
involved in the soups usable security
but also in the SS UCS kind of community
so I'm he's you know definitely a guy
he's known around town and we really
look forward to seeing what he's got to
say oh yeah so today I've orbit work
this talk will be the least security
talk that I ever gave and I said to talk
about mental models because I think some
of the interesting project that we have
in the lab they touch upon mental models
in one or the other form of mental
models of users and it looks like this
is kind of really something that if
usable security community doesn't
address then everything else will just
fall apart so I think mantech mental
models he is critical for for making
progress in usable security but in
general with security for EM users so
just to make sure that you're on the
same page mental model basically is
internal representation of external
world that helps us to predict and
explain things in the world and it helps
us specifically to understand
interaction with different artifacts
including computer defects
with computer artifacts went when we
have some some an artifact that by
function is similar to something else
for example calculator program then if
its interface is similar to what we
already know from from real world then
it helps us because now we can transfer
your mental model calculator that we
usually hold in our hands into into use
of computer so if you have a
computer-based calculator if its
interface is similar then it's easier
for us to navigate through the new phase
and we can predict and you can
understand the system state and
interaction with the system and then if
the interface changes our mental model
of of the 30 effect might change as well
it might be more complicated even more
sophisticated so this is all about us
developing mental models and and
interfaces through which we interact
with systems affecting our mental mental
models so how's mental model related to
other things besides our mental model
user mental model you also have a system
model that people who design and develop
systems have and then system model is
quite different from user mental model
it's much more complicated how do we
develop this our own user model it's
because people who design systems they
present us with design model in one or
the other form
so what I will talk about today is
mostly how design model and the
corresponding interfaces affect our user
mental models i will look at three
particular cases three different
projects that we have done recently in
my lab one was revealing how using
models affected by interfaces and
changes in the interface the second
project will describe our study of USC
proms and how the correlation we found
between understanding the UAC prompt and
correctly responding to AC proms and the
third project is still ongoing I'll
showed results of preliminary study in
that project where we looked into the
ability of open ID based authentication
so let's start with Windows Vista
personal firewall I don't have to
explain much about what it is it
basically blocks connections and if you
block connections depending on its state
it state depends on whether network that
computers connected to is classified as
either home or work or public location
and if it is home or work then it will
be mapped into so-called private
location type or if it is public
location to be mapped into public
location tab there is also another state
called the main and that in that case
the files completely controlled by
administrators of the Windows domain
which that machine / joint so for each
fridge that location public private or
the main the file we can can be
configured to block connections going
through either wired wireless or
Bluetooth interfaces the file has two
types of interfaces one is called
advanced interface and that interface is
not meant to be used by negligence multi
for advanced expert users so we didn't
really look carefully that interface
because we studied specifically how
regular users interact with the
firewalls and one more point here you
can see in the advanced interface you
can users can can configure that for
example for the main and for public the
firewall is on but for private profile
the firewall is off when the user only
looks at the basic interface it shows
the state of the firewall for that
particular profile at the public private
or domain and the profiles you remember
determined by the connection but you can
see there is inconsistency they the
firewall is on at the same time there is
a warning saying that the windows
firewall is not using the recommended
settings and it's very difficult for you
to figure out what exactly is going on
and why the user gets this morning and
this is because any changes to the
firewall whether it's turn on and off I
apply to the current profile and I not
apply to any other profile so if in one
profile the user to turn the firewall
often later in another profile when the
other profile was active that user turn
the firewall on you would get that
warning yet yet the firewall will show
that the interface will show the
firewall is on so when we realize that
also this interface hides the notion or
a different profiles and the fact that
changes are applied only to the current
profile so what we have done we looked
at alternative interfaces that would
review a little bit more about the state
of the firewall to the user and we came
up with the phone interface where these
you can see for each profile which
connections the firewall Chung blocks
and which connections it allows to go
through and also the user can have
access to the same information through a
simple table where they can see for each
profile and which type of connection
with the firewalls turn on or off so it
was done for Vista and it was we looked
at windows 7 and windows seven those
under some similarities and was very
interesting to see how our research
progress in parallel with what was going
on with Vista so any wanted to see how
the user interaction would change if the
users use our inter interface vs windows
firewall basic interface so we perform
the user study where we had 60
participants we had fairly
representative demographics of
participants and we wanted to study
first of all the mental model the
firewall by giving the user pictures or
icons of firewall internet and computer
and ask them to explain how the thing
those three things are related to each
other
that you did yeah yeah given the context
and then we ask them to perform specific
tasks with the firewall and then ask
them to and assess their after first
task we are asked them to assess mental
model we assess the mental model and
also add at the understanding of the
configuration and then we gave them
perform tasks with the second interface
and then again perform the assessment of
the mental model and configuration so
you wanted to see how the mental model
what what was that mental model before
they performed any tasks with different
interfaces then how it changed after
interacting with the first intervention
then the second interface and we get
within subject study where we would
alternate order of the interfaces
depending for different subjects so what
we found that our participants had
mental models of firewall of basically
four types incorrect where they would
not even understand where the firewall
actually is incomplete where they would
understand the firewalls between the
computer and the internet but they would
have no idea about context and network
location and connection and then
partially complete where they would have
this notion of different connections but
for example not the notion of location
type of location public private and so
on and for complete they would
demonstrate the understanding of or the
role the firewall types of connections
and and locations so the study did other
things but I want just to focus on the
adults that are most relevant to today
talk
for each so we had total 60 participants
yep yep
when we showed half of the participants
first vista basic fire interface and
then our prototype before this so any
interface 25 of them had incomplete
mental model and five had complete
mental model and then after this so
windows fire on the face when they
interact with it the number some of them
upgraded to incomplete from incorrect
and when they saw the prototype
interfaith interactive prototype
interface that was filled upgrade to
complete and partially complete mental
models another interesting so it it
shows us yeah so the motor is what is
make the right decisions yeah the fact
is yes yeah that's a good question i
have a slide that shows how it affected
decision well at least the equation
between order of the interfaces and the
decisions yeah it's a good point the
mental model doesn't have to be correct
it only needs to be adequate for
interacting with the system yeah hi I
had the complex yeah I think yeah
exactly yes oh yeah it can't get good at
all yeah it's about to yeah and it's a
very good point and the question here is
how much complex do you hide and how you
handed complex
so it's it's a fine balance you fight
too much complexity the users end up
with an adequate mental model I think
this is what we found in this study
so when we showed them shows the
prototype in that particular half of the
of our participants ample quite a number
of them upgraded to complete mental
model and the rest had only in complete
mental model the interesting thing was
not after this sir our prototype and
then this or Windows basic interface
interact it actually the meta modes that
downgraded which shows how sensitive
mental models of the users can be to the
interface through which they interact
with the system and going back to your
question what we found is that if they
had interacted with wrist interface
first and then alternative interface
later then they would have incorrect
understanding of whether the firewall is
on even though the firewall was at the
particular state at that moment was
actually off in 40 plus over forty
percent of the cases for public profile
and four and twenty six percent of the
cases for pride profile whereas when
they interacted with the accurate of
interface and then we stir the station
was somewhat better it wasn't perfect
but they do sound better so that's it
shows us that I think at least the
mental model that they had didn't allow
majority of them not matured majority
made the correct decision but still
substantial number of participants
actually couldn't make correct decision
couldn't assess correctly the state of
the firewall
yep standing back should one primary
objectives of researchers area be to
minimize the amount of interaction that
users you need to do with security
interfaces it because over long periods
of time recess is always consistently
shown users just don't get security yeah
our security doesn't get users here so
should be objectively then e we just try
to minimize the amount of interaction
that we need to have its key updating
the example are you sure I mean yo in
those seven should automatically set the
right people based on the location with
you of the conveyor apparently how sorry
way outside that my move I the level of
time my mom needs directly in fact
exactly it's a popular sentiment in the
usable security community and each sigh
community as well why don't we automate
the way security so that the users don't
have to interact at all so it you'll be
completely transparent for the users I
think the challenge is when they have to
interact if at the time they don't have
the right I'd equate mental model then
they make dangerous airs so that that's
the challenge if we can completely
automated security away than yes but if
we have to still show them something
when they show them something they
actually have to make correct decisions
so that's the change yeah for example
with firewall it would be nice as a
firewall if the user didn't have to
inject with the firewall but they
actually have to unfortunately and how
to especially if you if you take into
account variety of usages in a different
study that I'm not rip showing here
fahima interviewed participants about
what they expect from a firewall and one
thing they expected was that the
firewall took into account
the context of the usage of the gallop
top for example when they develop a
distribute application they have to
debug and they have to open ports
dynamically they don't want to see all
this for all these warnings so somehow
either the firewall itself or they have
to quickly in indicate the firewall that
okay I'm now developing in the
development mode and I'm going to debug
my application with another using
another server I don't want found out
getting in my way yeah so things like
this oh when I'm doing when I'm doing
online game again all the different
ports are open by the game I don't want
to be bothered with all this stuff
however when I work with on my online
banking tasks even though we know
security people know that it doesn't
matter if the malware gets in before or
during that particular interaction with
the online or online banking system is
already too late if the malware gets in
but these twos users expect that when
they interact with the online banking
system the firewall will be will tighten
up connections here so yeah the
challenge is if we cannot automate a way
how we still provide interfaces that
allow users to maintain adequate mental
models
I can then we'll say there are a lot of
opportunities to improve
our mission
that that much
as much the main door not a proportion
how do I should
yeah yeah and i think the windows vista
basic interface is an example where the
complex was hidden but because it was
hidden so so well the users ended up
developing an adequate mental model
so what can we learn from from that
particular case I'll first all users
develop and maintain the mental models
mostly through you I you can't expect
them to read the comment ation get
training all the stuff and you can see
that even changes in DUI can
substantially affect even children
changes in do I cannot affect them
mental model of the users that's an
argument about other making away and
also when we develop security interfaces
for the users and we test them we should
not only test for number of heirs time
to completion but also we want to test
their mental models and see whether the
mental moles are adequate the challenge
is to extract that mental model from the
users I think in the case of firewall is
fairly simple because you have firewall
laptop and internet cloud but what if
you have more complicated interface
weather is it's much more challenging to
somehow get that mental model
representation out of the users that
becomes the change specify some how
no not now we only looked at
specification Paris and one probably can
argue that our way off of reverse
engineering the mental model users maybe
was not absolutely correct you simply
cannot look at the mental model of year
where people don't understand when it's
on do you've any Clinton from plots on
what users think the dry me there's some
kinds of traffic that it blocks and
there's some kinds of traffic that let's
do they have any model of well you know
if the firewall is good and it protects
me why don't I just leave it on all the
time right there must be some model of
well it's blocking some things and
sometimes you want to let those things
room right zip it happens if it protects
me when I just leave it on all the time
you know did the model of when I want a
straight church on is that's that's
tricky right with in-depth I we didn't
look at that at all i think it was much
more decidable to have to be much more
complex but in the other study that i
just mentioned reheema asked
participants about the expectations
about firewall and one thing that she
found that no wises didn't want to have
any complex configuration of the
firewall they wanted something simple
like firewalls always one that's it and
whatever it blocks and whatever it lets
through however it was pic and figure it
by Microsoft or by whoever they just
wanted to be the same all the time they
don't want like to play with all the
different public versus private versus
domain profiles yeah yeah and that's
usually more advanced users who program
play games do things like this so it's
not a probably perfect answer for but we
didn't look into fine grain details I'm
sure the scripts for example network
administrators have much more fitting
model travels and even advanced users on
on on personal computers because the
complexity of the discussion that we had
to have what users is large right if you
know okay if you want it on that's fine
but it's tell you that it's sometimes
some classes of traffic one sometimes to
be my frugal here's why you might want
to do that that's that open yeah big cam
complexity of the model yes because you
never feel so that another use of a
model is for when you find situations
that you
because if you just try to call figure 1
mmm
I think one of the things that ok so I
Stella go Stella that our windows a
window pops up saying a running this
program
that's when i'm in a model would so
this petticoat epic search
you got a new measure organic we didn't
go that route what we did was
recommended just as her last project was
use of physical security metaphor for
firewall warnings because what she found
is that users mostly interact with the
firewall not through this even through
the basic interface they interact with
the firewall mostly through warnings
that the firewall gives them and she
wanted to see if use of familiar
metaphor would help them to appreciate
the type of a decision they have to make
yeah so but you all right if if the user
has to do something that kind of out of
main trunk than the importance of mental
model even increases further yeah
there's something that jumped out at me
I'd like to get your thoughts on if it's
something we can learn from this which
is that you should users one UI they
ended up with one mental model do
immediately shut them another you are in
another mental model it strikes me that
a lot of the attacks which are driven by
confusing the user including fishing and
convincing the user to install some
piece of church or software can I might
actually be sort of similar in that they
to do something to shift the users
mental model and that these models are
highly plastic and subject to
manipulation do you think that's a fair
take away yeah I think so so I was
surprised how much mental model was
affected by differences in the interface
yeah yeah it could it could very well be
the case and I I suspect that user
mental model of walls with interactions
so the when the users get exposed to
different types of interactions example
fission side then their model mental
model changes and a security community
we cannot control that how that mental
model change because it's basically the
interact with fish inside with you the
fishes can influence the mental model of
the users yep yes especially were I mean
that case we show that they're metal
bomb degraded when they have pretty good
mental on what was going
is all set it's not very robust it
doesn't if it doesn't hold up under 200
pound to be optimistic I think these are
mental models which are not exercised
very often yeah exactly don't have a lot
of history yeah and so maybe that two
g-packs point one of the things that
happens if we don't put security in
front of users is it's always weird
subject to manipulation yeah becomes
fragile it's obviously difficult
elements of they don't know a lot of
Giovanni arrest there's no reinforcement
of the bottom and put that one in one
thing with perspectives on all the cuts
exactly yes you should fine yeah I guess
that's how if you think about bro gave
I saw something they all the common
things that they all wanted lyrics wikia
kids i always i give and also like that
this question right if how many mac
users will fall for that trick the
windows uses water technically shoulders
are so many prongs we show them so many
messages on your bias is yeah on a Mac
user say like hey I don't have viruses
you know it's an opinion I also will
take pay some more than money I've been
saying that they probably would not
click on that and say this is too bad i
think that was a great research what's
true that that could actually do
interesting way of saying we should do a
study by mikey considering driving an
effort
the fact to remove all the notification
actually impacts the perception that we
have max but doesn't MSC you want to
show this nike probably yeah we all do
yeah since you mentioned Mac I have my
own experience with Max wish I foundry
you can weird because it doesn't meet
fit into my mentor model Oh Mac firewall
and that is I can figure Mac firewall to
be on it has a very simple interface and
it allows you to put exceptions for
different applications but Mac also has
very convenient way often transferring
all your data and configuration to a new
laptop when you get a new laptop or
desktop it's very easy to transfer
however when you transfer things and you
start using new machine it turns out
that the firewall settings will not be
transferred completely for example the
firewall on the old machine was on but
on the new motion that you always be off
no matter how much configuration you
transfer from old machines in immersion
really strange for me but let's move on
with with the next study where our other
student Sarah investigated user account
control practices
so the reason why she wanted to look at
it is she wanted to see how technology
operating system technology supports the
principal is privileged and how that can
be improved so in the pins according to
the principle is marriage you should get
at least three just possible in order to
form their tasks and specifically in
most of the consumer operating systems
but specifically in Windows it's
achieved through first of all so-called
low British user account where you
supposed to stand up the count rather
than admin account and also through a
way of escalating peerages when it's
necessary and escalation of peerages is
in Windows referred as user account
control UAC one can turn the arm one can
select the type of account and once the
selected type of account they can also
turn UAC prompt off or on when the
prompts are on depending on the type of
application the prompt you look somewhat
different this bar would have different
color and they would be different icon
here and the user is basically asked to
continue with liking the particular
application to escalate its peerages or
basically crashing that application or
stopping that process and if the user
user admin account then these doesn't
have to provide password otherwise user
has to provide password admin password
on the machine so the UAC and low
previous user account they support each
other in the phone form
you can be on and off and if he if the
USC is off then and the user uses
standard account then the principal a
spirit would be followed if the USC that
but it also means that you will not get
any neh eproms but which means that all
the applications all protesters that
require privilege escalation will be
automatically denied that request if the
user uses admin account then the
principal speech will not default
because that means that any process
request in this collection of purchase
will get muchly granted these privileges
and same thing when you AC is on an
office you can choose between admin asst
entered account when the user uses admin
account and you AC is on if you respond
correctly to the USC prompts the PLP is
forward otherwise it's not same thing
for standard account so the bottom line
of our study is the phone first of all
all of our 45 participants actually used
admin account we asked them to bring
their own laptops for the study and
turns out they all use admin accounts so
that means that they all here and here
and we also found that I'll explain what
it means that they correctly respond or
incorrectly respond to AC proms we found
that again first of all twenty percent
don't have here AC proms on and another
almost fifty percent don't respond to AC
problems correctly so it's about seventy
percent as Rob actually made a comment
that this can be interpreted as a good
news as world means that this thirty
percent of the users actually do
followed the principles beverage
your baseline next yeah yeah active yeah
hers is low enough three percent was
pretty awesome yea though I is 27 s so
rounding up till they're each other off
I'll actually little bit after the only
twenty percent of people turning off you
a city violates my mental model so we
get vision study within subjects left
study but users brought their own
laptops and they didn't give them
detailed distractions like do these do
that the tasks are fairly general as you
can see and not accompanied by detailed
instructions and they also perform
screen recording but we found that
screen recording does not actually
capture the USC prompts so we also had
to do video recording of the screen so
we give some setup of the context and
then ask them to install screen
recordings program and that program also
had another program inside of it so
during this installation process another
program was installed it was a little
bit of deception which we needed for the
study and then we asked them to perform
different tasks we asked them for
example download find some application
on internet for playing dvds and
installed and then another task this is
a USB stick with a text editor installed
it textile it on your machine and third
task there is particular spyware remover
application again find it on internet
downloaded and installed so the task of
a genuine we didn't tell them exactly
where it should go which application
which DVD player should install but in
these two tasks the instructions through
little bit more specific
and then when they were performing these
tasks we triggered in addition to
whatever problems they had because of
performing those tasks we also should
get to other proms one prompt we call
them it's random from it was triggered
by application that was wrapped in the
screen recorded installation package
that exactly after three minutes of
after that the installation was complete
it would perform a particular action
that led to escalation privilege and UAC
prompt if the uShip from us he was
turned on so it wasn't completely random
but it was not associated with anybody
specific task it was not triggered by
user actions except that the
installation of the screen recorder so
that was the prompt and we may be
instrumented triggering in a way that
the program name would be completely
kind of unrelated to the user stuff
update cash what the heck it is it's not
related to text editor is not related to
the screen record installation and then
when they were installing text editor
when decided installation right before
the USC prom that would come up because
of the installation we managed to
trigger another prompt that looked very
much like the text editor so it had a
name that is resemble some something
like text editor helper but it wasn't
triggered by the extra text editor
package it was triggered by some other
application so it was helped to text
object hawk where's so that was
triggered by kind of not malicious but
our our our application where's this one
prompt was triggered by by the
installation of the text editor
and then we interviewed them we show
them some of the video that we recorded
from the session and ask why they
interacted on responding to your see
problems in this or the other way and
then we also did ask them to perform
specific task for Lu a I'm not going to
discuss them because it doesn't generate
much to mental models and then we
performed another interview so this is a
typical timeline of the users tasks so
installation of this recorder then
perform the first task and this is
approximately where random tag prompt
will be triggered and that's another
problem that was triggered by the
installation of the DVD player and then
in the installation of text editor that
would be first our prompt before they
would see a legitimate prompt and then
in the installation of the spyware they
would have another prompt so we had
fairly diverse set of participants as
well and we use basic analysis of
qualitative data through card sajan
approach and perform statistical
analysis of quantitative data we also
try to see if there is any statistically
significant difference between windows
vista and windows seven participants we
had 30 windows vista and 15 windows
seven participants we didn't find any
statistically significant difference so
if users perform interact respond to
your serums correctly then they would
not allow they would not consent to the
random prom that we had what we found is
that half of them consented to the
random prompt
twenty percent of them had the UC
disabled suit they didn't see the prompt
at all they owe our and 26 cancelled the
prompt so it's about twenty-five percent
some of them did not noticed because
they were doing something else and as a
result the AC prompt was just some
blinking win-win doing the task bar now
we try to keep the study as ecologically
valid as possible so we didn't cover oh
look you have some bling in there and
then when we late interview them and ask
why you can send it to this prompt what
we found that they more than half of
them so that it was related to the
activity even though the prompt was
absolutely about something different
almost Pheebs of them said that they
always consent to any AC prompt and some
of them thought that it was to update
system because it was cash update I
can't remember exactly what these five
percent moving to the next step maybe
there was installation we thought it was
something about installing installation
of the DVD player some of them just just
consented I don't know
so what we can conclude we can conclude
that participants when they download and
install and run application they do it
correctly respond to us he promised
because somehow they saw that is related
to the task at hand so which brings up a
question what's the mental model of the
participants about your AC prompts how
many they should expect all those UAC
prompt and because they interact only
with you a see through those prompts I
don't think there is clear expectation
on the side of the users how many they
should expect for each installation for
example is it 12 how many it I suspect
the depends on particular installation
package which means that the mental
model of the participants about the AC
proms is not really robust because they
don't know how commonly they should
expect what what the name of the program
that is legitimate part of the package
versus some malware that is trying to
perform something else doing a user
activities okay because we have only it
means left I want to move on I just want
to show interesting fact that for those
problems that we're right before the
legitimate prom so the initiated action
of installing text edit and then this is
the first prompt and the first problem
says something about Jack stated that
they even though it was triggered by
absolutely different application
different process ninety-five percent of
them consented to this problem so this
is perfect way for malware just wait for
some process with name install start
runyon in the system and and they just
if perform request for rich escalation
ok so the conclusions our you discuss
them what can we learn from this case
study in terms of mental models so again
you can see that this is another example
of the fact that users develop them and
maintain the mental models through
interactions with the user interface and
only with the user interface but in case
of us eproms i think the mental model is
effected through our evolved through
multiple interactions with prams because
they seem many of them so it's not just
based on what they read in the prompt
and how the prompt looks but when those
prompts pop up what are the consequences
of consenting or canceling these prompts
and that affects the mental model that
the user build and this is I think
lesson that Cormac and I keep kind of
discussing that this is really critical
and that is if for example you see
prompt design hinges on the ability of
the user to notice the inconsistency for
example i'm supposed to get one prom but
am I getting too what's going on then
the UI should be very very consistent so
that the users will eventually develop
this mental model of prompts or any
other interface consistency they need to
understand which part of the interfaces
is consistent and which parts are not
consistent so sorry presented actually
this work last July he actually it in
comments during soups so third case
study I think is quite interesting and
maybe it's also kind of pleasing for you
because it's not just about Microsoft
Technology it's about something else and
that's one of things I put it at the end
and
happy thereafter so about open ID open
ID is used because we have too many
passwords as we all know here and what
options we have and also we have we have
to maintain too many profiles online
which just cumbersome and too
inconvenient for users what options we
have we can use use password managers or
we can use so-called web single sign-on
would see web single sign-on it's
something that requires our user to have
identity managed by so called identity
provider IDP and when users sign up and
sign into different service providers
which are referred as relying parties
they use a banded key they authenticate
with event provided and credentials are
passed to you relying party so idea is
very simple it's very nice to do however
if you looked at the protocol is fairly
sophisticated the technology behind the
interfaces of open ID is probably one of
the most complex that users have to face
these days in terms of cute technology
to all these interactions have to be
done fortunately they don't yeah
so the users don't see fortunately all
this stuff instead they see various open
ID where's interfaces for sign signing
in with different airline pilots using
the open ID identity providers but what
you probably notice already these
interfaces are all somewhat different
they are not consistent not only they
are not consistent is not clear what
kind of mental model dish they develop
in the users for example if I use let's
say Facebook as my identity provider do
I put anything here and then click on
Facebook or I first click on Facebook or
I just put stuff that my username a
password for facebook and just click
login because the service provider
already knows how to figure out that
it's my facebook account it's not clear
so sansai is working on web signal sign
on and one of the he wanted to improve
things but they told him again so look
before you start improving figure out
what's wrong so I said ok I'm going to
do a small user study as part of my
grated course in each time and they
performed a small study with just nine
participants which is not very
representative these are fairly active
participants they had more than four web
accounts some two of them use password
managers and five of the nine use kind
of single sign-on single user name and
password solution that we have at UBC
code campus-wide login so the user
besides doing questionnaire they also
will ask to use the existing identity
provider to sign up and then sign in
into three different
different to relying parties and then
after they logged in we told them okay
imagine that you are at the public
computer so you look logged in at those
sites you checked your news check the
other things now make sure that you log
out so that nobody else who will walk up
to this public computer you will be able
to use your identity anywhere they all
they did what they could they did their
best and then on the fourth step we told
them ok so now go to this specific URL
and select Yahoo Yahoo as the account
that you useful again and then see if
you can identify whether this is
efficient side or not so when the users
select it in the previous screen shirt
Yahoo and click on this button
eventually this page I peered out in
Joan because it's a German side and we
are going to try to find any way to tell
that this is not the real google or
yahoo website and most of them pretty
much all of them identify they decide
well look this is URL that is is not
related but they said that they were all
concerned that if they look primed
before that this most likely phishing
site in real life they would not be able
to figure out this is not the actual
identity provider and then we perform
that equation and contextual interview
so the first finding is that most of the
users had incorrect initial mental model
of how authentication actually is done
with open again majority of them
actually typed their credentials here
and then clicked on the identity
provider that they use then that was for
signup when they perform signup process
and now they needed to sign in they also
had an inadequate mental model that they
derive from the login process they again
follow them type the username and
password of the identity provider rather
than perform enough authentication with
the dental provider another finding was
that they didn't know majority of them
didn't know that they had to click on
the identity provider before they can I
really should type the username and
password some of them thought that it
was just a detachment of the different
identity providers and some of the
thought in the sense yes yeah because we
are all used so much to all these ads
everywhere too so that that website
somehow integrated with identity
providers so that didn't have to go
anywhere they would just type that in
key priorities credentials and login
which is I think it's a good mental
model if the technology could support it
why would there be why would I want to
be redirected to another page to type in
my username positive if I already
basically trust this service provider
and i'm using my identity providers
credentials only for the purpose of
convenience another another other
findings that we had was that users were
confused what it means for them to sign
up for the service provider using the
identity providers credentials and then
somehow again provide the name first
name last name email address
all that information and some providers
even ask just in case we cannot connect
to your identity provider set up your
username and password here too another
thing that the really concern was that
when they thought they logged out of all
the accounts as if they would do in a
public settings we later asked them a
cake go back for example to you google
and check your mail they clicked on on
gmail URL or type gmail URL and they
found that they've already logged in
they didn't have to do anything because
it turns out even if you logged out of
your relying parties you have explicitly
to logout from identity provider in
order for this web browser being
completely empty of your of your session
and credentials so what can we learn
from this particular study again user
develop and maintain their mental models
through the UI and mental models have to
be adequate not just users shouldn't
perform tasks fast and without making
errors but another interesting lesson I
think we can learn here but mental
models is that when we combine regular
password authentication for example for
service providers with this verb single
sign-on we want to be careful because
the mental model for web single sign-on
at least four point ID is significantly
different has to be significantly
different from the mental model of
regular password based authentication on
the web when we combine these two
interfaces together we want to be really
careful about what kind of mental model
users end up developing and whether that
mental model can be adequate so this is
summary of the of the lessons that they
are discussed yeah
and this point I want to open powerful
questions here so I do i do computer
system designer I main tell you about
these things in the context of by
designing in your system running from
your experience period starting existing
designs that they're trying to see what
mental ones work and having you guys on
top if you have buy recommendations for
how to actually just change the design
itself and what should that chain those
changes be trying to do yeah
unfortunately my answer is that I don't
know answer to that question but what I
would I learn from from this myself is
that whatever design you do and it
depends a difficult to type of type of
security or other technology to use it's
critical to not only test that interface
with participants on the completion time
and number of errors that make like
actually try to figure out what exactly
the mental model is how adequate it is
and testing mental models is necessary
to make sure that users in non-standard
situations or even in standard citations
will will actually interact with the
interfaces correctly from a little bit
of like this is some design philosophy
tends to mean separation of policy in
mechanism yeah and the kind of thing
you're saying it seems it seems to run
into that like policies may change over
time so if you end up marrying the
design too tightly with today's policies
then tomorrow when something else
happens then you need to redesign your
system yeah it depends significantly on
how how much the policy changes yeah so
usually separation between policies and
mechanisms is explained in the context
of access control when we have a policy
decision point that is a black box from
point of view of policy enforcement
point and PDP somehow makes a decision
to deny or allow access and then PP
enforces and PP sits between the user or
the subject and the protected resources
so the user if the user is exposed to
now these security mechanisms it's
usually through the interaction with the
policy enforcement point so in that
access control context changing policies
shouldn't be a big deal so these
shouldn't be affected the the mental
model it shouldn't be affected by
changing the policies because policies
just in
it is out in denial or allow type of
decisions when we talk about
authentication for example if
authentication let's say policies change
then the user interface might have to be
changed as well or might start behaving
differently as so for example they
service provider decides that they don't
trust Google anymore and therefore the
users who used to have account with the
service provider but used Google as they
IDP would be forced to audits which the
different search IDP provider or use the
username and password that they saved
with the service provider then the
authentication experience would change
by necessity and that change will most
likely affect the mental model so in
that sense you are right that that in
for some particular security functions
the change in the policy might result in
change in the changes of the experience
of the user great to reconcile
dispensers like keeping keeping the
system evolve
by not tying the Metro design too
tightly to cut existing metropolitan
policies and still not have these kinds
of gaps that you're hiking the mental
model
today I don't have the toll
I me in idea world when policy changes
if the policy changes substantially then
it's not just the matter of like
some permissions change or some role
assignments change in the system but the
significant changes in the policy for
example type of authentication use
changes or who can be identity provider
for the particular service provided
those things change the interaction with
the between the service security
services or security functions and the
users have to be pretty much be related
I don't see how it can be done I think
it's very challenged it's very difficult
to completely hide such changes from the
users or preserve the interaction
in in the interviews in the open ID
study did anyone raise the issue of
jargon that they didn't understand I
definitely are
provider no I haven't I haven't seen
that as one of the results I think the
study was purposefully avoiding the
jargon
ok
she use Google you have you can
authenticate Google try to do that here
yeah but yeah
and some of the open ID open ID based
authentication interface with they do
use dragon
was there anything feedback from people
i mean most of this was their
introduction to open ID right they
didn't know about it before Wow yeah was
there any kind of feedback is a post
game on wow this is great I can't
believe I didn't know about this before
I use every day or you know for crying
out loud why why would I want to stop to
this nonsense no we didn't have either
ways
yeah i think that type of feedback can
become like it when you do a longer
study like deployment it was something
like they did the mismatch between what
they thought like typing the wrong you
know
password into into the box is like that
gap between their model and what's
actually going on would go away if the
user you know three or four times right
yeah yeah many things that you don't
yeah yeah but we will succeed to this
see the value they imagine those users
who have to interact with the system
without anybody and anybody's help and
this had a case or I don't want to
create a another count out just use my
yahoo then how do they figure out how
how they should interact with the system
so it can be so much frustrating that
they would just give up on the on the
idea of using yahoo account for login
into fox news
but it also shows I thing is that it
could be other problems that we didn't
uncover in this small scale study
especially if if we if we looked at
longer usage users
but the other the penetration of
indicates that there are problems
which is a subject of a different paper
by society yeah yep rhetoric mental
models is a classically hard problem I
think that a really nice job Chuck y
which is that they're they're often a
moving target have a very great big base
on the interface that you present
I'm wondering though if you have a sense
of whether there are any constants in
these are mental models and least in
case you study whether there are things
that preconceptions that people come to
these problems with that are invariant
depending on why the desi
every matic dramatic elements of the
mental model that they conceive them
difficult to change well yeah or that
are maybe already corrected we can kind
of count on yeah it is desired yeah yeah
yeah good good it's Bucky optimistic
sorry I say whatever you wish such as I
can't just despair that is actually on
the 707 are all mixed up with no I
suspect actually the preconception this
very strong preconceptions there you
have my conception but i think it's
rational conclusion is that I always
click through and nothing happened to me
so far in five years of my musician and
Peter's that's very difficult to change
and I don't have time for
carefully considering this stuff I think
these are things that this big machine
regression model
so it's only bad stuff that is already
there's no yeah they're no good things
that we I think the fact that the users
type the IDP credentials in the relying
parties in the name and password fields
meet tells that
if the user is RK it wants to sign up
for the service they pretty much already
trust that that your show is provided
with pretty much everything they have on
automatically in their passwords from
other service priorities
there were there was one of us either
they decide to work
are they sure that not giving that site
access to their
mm-hmm
yeah I don't know it's a good question
because this is what happens when you
log in into or sign up to service
provider using facebook connect it tells
it asks you whether it can on your
behalf access all your data post on your
wall which must do everything for you
and I try the several times to say no
and then they will just give me no
service yeah so I think this is whether
they want or not but I think they have
to I slab that service provider to do
much everything with the account at the
IDP
and i'm not sure i think we as a
community basically forcing users to
develop this mental model if I trust one
I have to trust everybody where I use
with everything that i have on all these
services
thank God